alguns dias atrás eu estava em casa
tomando chá e aí eu comecei a fazer o
que eu mais sei fazer na vida
mas posso te fazendo que é pensar na
vida olhando pela janela segurando a
minha caneca de chá
você nunca pensa em coisas superficiais
é sempre pensa em coisas profundas
existenciais e comecei a pensar que tem
algo de muito grandioso acontecendo na
minha vida eu queria compartilhar isso
com vocês aqui é curioso pensar na vida
tão extraordinária hoje porque seis
meses atrás a minha vida bem diferente
seis meses atrás passando pelo período
mais difícil da minha vida empreendedora
sete anos e fazia dois anos que eu venho
perdendo meu terceiro negócio é deixar
os dois negócios pra trás pra postar uma
idéia que eu achava que era incrível que
as pessoas me diziam que era muito boa e
que não tinha como dar errado estava
dando errado abrir muitas oportunidades
mas não conseguia fechar os colocando
seu dinheiro
o dinheiro foi acabando e eu não
conseguia equilibrar as contas não
deixar ainda no azul e não conseguia
fazê la de colar não conseguia também
busca um investidor que apostasse na
minha ideia para conseguir alavancar a
ela o dinheiro foi acabando como faziam
chegando a conta chegava eu não sabia o
que fazer mais com elas simplesmente
deixava elas no canto no escritório
elas vinham nem abrir porque sabia que
não ia ter dinheiro para pagar
eu deixava no canto depois de um dia de
muito de muito esforço e trabalho muito
duro e de mais decepções más notícias
eu senti que tinha chegado no meu limite
me agüenta mais e que eu tinha que fazer
alguma coisa para resolver aquilo que eu
tinha que encarar meu medo de frente que
eu tinha que olhar para a minha conta
bancária que não cessava alguns meses
que eu tinha que olhar para aquela ilha
de kos estava chegando e não conseguia
pagar eu tinha que fazer alguma coisa em
relação a isso
então o que eu fiz foi abrir o
computador
eu comecei a escrever
e eu sempre tive escrita com minha
válvula de escape como forma de ter
contato com as minhas emoções de contato
com os meus sentimentos e colocar isso
para fora para que de alguma forma
conseguir conseguir se entender melhor e
da mesma maneira eu conseguisse aliviar
um pouco o sofrimento que eu tinha então
conseguiu chegar em casa comecei a
escrever eu coloquei todo o meu coração
naquelas teclas
então a primeira vez na vida eu senti
que estava sendo verdadeiro comigo mesmo
pela primeira vez na vida eu senti que
estava sendo sincero e comecei a ver
parte de mim que eu não estava querendo
enxergar muitos anos e comecei a lembrar
de muita coisa comecei a lembrar de sons
que tinha abandonado durante 11 dias
escrevia todos os dias pela noite todos
os dias pela manhã e durante o dia eu ia
resolver a minha vida eu e as conversas
difíceis que estava evitando falar com
as pessoas que não queria conversar
encerrar a conta em banco insular cartão
de crédito filme desfazer de bens que
achava que nunca poderia abrir mão para
conseguir resolver
ao final desses 11 dias eu senti que eu
tinha passado por um processo de
transformação que aquilo tinha mexido
comigo de alguma forma eu senti que eu
estava livre de várias amarras de vários
medos que eu tinha eu entendi que eles
não existiam de verdade são todos da
minha cabeça
o décimo segundo dia eu reflito do que
eu tinha escrito e eu vi que tinha
escrito um livro eu fechei esse livro
mandei pra algumas pessoas e elas
começaram a dizer que aquele conteúdo
era muito forte que estava transformando
elas queriam que eu compartilhasse com a
gente então eu tomei coragem e
compartilhar com o mundo
coloquei o livro disponível na internet
em menos de um mês foram mais de 2 mil
pessoas que leram um livro e começaram a
me mandar mensagens dizendo que estamos
transformando que estavam tomando
coragem para conseguir fazer coisas que
elas nunca conseguiu fazer na vida
naquele momento eu entendi que minha
vida tinha mudado de verdade porque dali
pra frente e começar a acontecer
sincronicidades engraçado pensar isso
porque eu sempre quis ser um escritor
sempre sonhava escrever mas achava que
não era possível
quem é e quem sou eu pra escrever um
livro quem vai querer ler
achava que o tinha que ser um milionário
eu tinha que conquistar o mundo que eu
tinha aqui tem empresa ter vendido
empresas e capa de revista para
precificar um livro as pessoas não lê ou
então depois que já tivesse começado
muito dinheiro podia me dar ao luxo de
tirar um período sabático de um ano
alongar uma cabana nas montanhas isolado
nas montanhas de lá depois eu ia descer
com isso pronto
só que nada disso precisou acontecer
depois de duas semanas eu tinha um livro
pronto ea simplicidade começaram a
aparecer na minha vida eu comecei a
conhecer gente incrível e as pessoas
começaram a vir me procurar e depois de
três meses e estava com um livro pronto
publicado à venda nas livrarias este
livro descreve o modelo de uma nova
economia de uma nova sociedade baseada
na confiança baseada no amor e do bom
senso
então peguei essa empresa que eu tinha
cheguei com alguns amigos e falar o
seguinte eu coloquei todo o meu dinheiro
aqui todo dinheiro que eu tenho o
dinheiro que eu não tenho
a partir de agora eu não quero que ela
seja só minha quero dividir com vocês eu
quero criar um novo modelo e quer fazer
uma experiência que nunca é uma empresa
totalmente horizontal totalmente
horizontal onde todo mundo é igual
onde um ganha mais do que o outro onde a
minha participação não é maior que a de
ninguém
cada um é livre para escolher como quer
se envolver e conversei com alguns
amigos e achei que no começo isso sem
falar que eu estava louco que estava
viajando que aquilo não fazia sentido
que era utópico mas é começar a me
surpreender e ver que eles acreditavam
nisso
de repente eu vi que ele estava mais
sozinho que era uma cinco dez quinze
vinte pessoas
depois em menos de duas semanas e monta
o time de 20 pessoas incríveis um
talento muito diferentes
edmonton movimento a gente uma empresa
livre empresa de uma empresa de cada um
é livre para escolher como quer se
envolver
você escolhe criatividade você quer
fazer quantas horas você quer se dedicar
por semana de onde você quer trabalhar a
gente se une pela complementaridade para
que o outro possa fazer aquilo que eu
não sei fazer
ao invés de ficar perdendo tempo fazendo
aquilo que eu não sei fazer e que vai
ficar minha boca e deixou outra pessoa
fazer uma pessoa que ama fazer aquilo
que eu não gosto
a gente começou a trabalhar com
com esse time na criação de quatro
etapas de tecnologia que tem como
propósito em poder às pessoas para que
as pessoas possam aprender as suas
próprias vidas e ganhar dinheiro de uma
outra forma sem depender do modelo do
emprego tem sido um grande desafio a
gente tem feito muita coisa tem
aprendido muito é muito difícil criar um
novo quando se não tem referência
as pessoas me perguntavam o que vai
acontecer quando um briga com outro
quando acontecer uma coisa quando quiser
ganhar passa a perna e falou sei lá
nem sei se vai acontecer e isso é e se
acontecer a gente vai resolver
como tudo na vida eu vi me conectar com
essas pessoas que o meu sonho também era
o sonho delas que não estava sozinho
se eu pensar já é isso que o seu sonho
também o sonho de outras pessoas
então se o seu sonho também o sonho dele
você só tem que se conectar
é interessante pensar que a gente não
aprendeu a colaborar
a gente aprendeu competir dependeu
garantiu nós porque é escassa e garantiu
mesmo porque não sei se vai ter pra todo
mundo né
só que para colaborar gente tem que
baixar a guarda e baixar nossas marcas
para se conectar de verdade
então nesses últimos meses eu comecei a
conhecer tanta gente incrível depois de
tantos movimentos interessantes de
economia colaborativa movimentos em rede
movimentos muito interessantes que me
fez enxergar a vida de outra forma
começaram a me mostrar que tinha mais
coisas acontecendo que não estava na
televisão
então resolvi escrever um texto para
compartilhar essa visão seja um texto
chamado algo de grandioso acontecendo no
mundo
nesse texto e compartilhar minha visão
de 8 movimento que vem acontecendo
as mudanças do mundo corporativo as
mudanças do empreendedorismo com pessoas
lembrando de outras formas
o ressurgimento da colaboração poder da
internet
a queda no consumo alimentação orgânica
espetada espiritualidade movimento de
descolonização todos esses oito
movimentos mostram que tem coisas que
podem transformar a sociedade diz o
texto
tentei ser o mais objetivo possível fez
uma síntese joguei na internet e
compartilhar no facebook algumas pessoas
e as pessoas começaram a compartilhar
de compartilhar e curtir e compartilhar
e foi afastado com aquilo porque comecei
a ver que há mais gente compartilhando a
gente que eu nem conhecia as pessoas
começaram a mencionar no facebook eu não
sabia nem o que fazer com aquilo que eu
resolvi aceitar e deixaram dezenas
centenas milhares de pessoas começaram a
mencionar no facebook introduziu o
inglês esse livro esse texto
aí comecei a receber mensagens de gente
do mundo inteiro na austrália do canadá
da turquia à bulgária da história do
japão da espanha da holanda e da
finlândia e do mundo inteiro começou a
mandar mensagem dizendo que acreditava
na mesma coisa que via o mundo da mesma
forma o hit que dizia não se achava que
era o pt
e só eu pensava assim mas é legal ver
que tem mais gente né que também está
compartilhando no começo eu ficava um
pouco ansioso porque não conseguia
responder a todas as mensagens
depois não conseguia nem ler todas as
mensagens mas eu consegui ver que de
fato tem algo de grandioso acontecendo
no mundo sim e aí olho para trás e vejo
tudo o que aconteceu hoje eu tô aqui pra
vocês e achava que só poderia acontecer
o dia que eu fosse um milionário onde é
que eu tivesse vendido as minhas
empresas que fosse capa da revista
mas seis meses atrás eu estava numa
situação completamente diferente eu olho
para trás e vejo que será que aconteceu
nesses seis meses porque minha vida
transformou tanto porque eu saí do
esforço de não conseguir pagar as minhas
contas para estar aqui realizando todos
os meus sonhos mais risco mobilizando
pessoas para que elas consigam realizar
os sonhos delas também
a resposta que me vem é que foi uma
única coisa que aconteceu eu vou ser
verdadeiro comigo mesmo
eu posso aceitar quem eu sou de verdade
eu passei a escutar eu deixei de escutar
as pessoas deixem de escutar o que os
outros diziam que eu deveria fazer
eu cheguei a escutar o que a sociedade
dizia que eu deveria fazer de como as
coisas funcionavam desde que irá
replicar modelos
eu passei a criar os meus próprios
modelos isso é muito difícil
especialmente no mundo onde a gente ruim
de fórmulas de sucesso tenta replicar o
conceito de outras pessoas e eu falo
tudo isso aqui pessoal compartilhando
tudo isso para que vocês fazem não olha
que interessante que acontece na vida
desse cara
não porque o que aconteceu comigo pode
acontecer com vocês também quis olhar
assim pra vocês pensasse que vocês não
estão enxergando dentro de vocês
questões que vocês deixaram morrer
talvez você tenha se esquecido mas só
ele morre
ele pensa adormece ele esperando o
momento para se manifestar
eles para vocês se enfraquecer para você
cair aparecer e quando você se conecta
com o seu som é quando você se conecta
com quem você é de verdade
você começa a ver uma outra realidade
tudo muda na sua vida
eu tentava ter sucesso
aí sim poder fazer as coisas que
gostaria de fazer hoje vou dizer uma
coisa que quero fazer é um caso de
sucesso pra isso eu não quero mais ter
sucesso só quero ser feliz e depois de
depois de muito pesquisar de muito
entender de muito ler eu cheguei no meu
conceito de felicidade
o terminal que a minha participação
compartilhar com vocês pois todo esse
processo desses últimos meses eu entendi
que felicidade é o que acontece quando
você é quem você é de verdade
obrigado
o velho